[Musique]
je vais encore je vais encore avoir le
même discours j'ai découvert un truc
génial et je crois pas que personne
demandée par les avants c'est fou vous
connaissez tous switch aujourd'hui en
2020 c'est pas possible connaissiez pas
fait d'ailleurs la fiabilité la flemme
sur twitch y a plein de catégories
certaines de ces catégories c'est des
jeux d'autres c'est du jazz talking
sujet des gens qui parlent qui raconte
des trucs et de leurs communautés et ya
aussi des catégories un peu plus large
qui englobe par exemple de la musique
des événements et dans toutes ces
catégories il ya la catégorie sciences
et technologies soyez excité cette
catégorie là fait très très peu de vue
ans va pas se mentir ça suscite pas tant
l'intérêt alors c'est génial dans cette
catégorie là vous pouvez retrouver des
gens qui font des trucs un peu de gros
gros geek il ya des gens qui codent des
jeux il ya des gens qui codent des
logiciels il ya des gens qui montent des
pc il ya des poulaillers ya des
poulaillers ok il y à des fermiers et
des gens qui ont des grands jardins et
des animaux qui se sont amusés à mettre
des caméras
là où il ya leurs animaux ça peut être
des poules des chèvres des moutons des
n'importe quoi des canards et tu peux
voir leurs animaux 24 heures sur 24
d'accord soyez excité vous allez
regretter je trouve ça génial pour la
simple et bonne raison que déjà tu peux
voir la vie des animaux c'est hyper
intéressant moi j'adore les animaux vous
le savez et surtout tu peut interagir
avec eux il ya certes un live où tu peux
en faisant une donation leur donner
instantanément à manger ses joueurs un
truc automatisé c'est pas un gars qui
vient alors bien évidemment c'est
réguler tu peux pas leur donner à manger
à l'infini parce que sinon il sera en
mauvaise santé
là c'est bien régulé et c'est hilarant
je vous jure j'ai eu des fous rires on
va faire un tour de sa ensemble et vous
n'allez plus jamais prendre de haut
d'accord plus jamais là on est sur un
live on peut non pas donner à manger aux
animaux on peut activer cette petite
fontaine grenouille attention des
personnes ça fait toujours quelque chose
à première fois dites moi que c'est
sympa la dernière fois j'ai vu des
écureuils et des oiseaux passé
mais là y'a rien là y'a bien vert mais
pas une araignée d'eau c'est un colibri
des hautes montagnes
je le reconnais il est parti c'est la
sociale ramos ionel ses lives écoutez je
vis a traversé la crise que ressent un
peu à vous savez les ceux qui font des
reportages animaliers t qui sont à la
recherche du loup blanc hyper rare de
sibérie et enfin il tombe dessus bah moi
je fais ça dans une moindre mesure ça
peut être un moineau je suis content en
fait je peux me dire j'ai été là au
moment où il y avait l'oiseau au ventre
rouge sur le live voilà acheta que
j'étais là où ici par exemple c'est des
écureuils
mais attends c'est rempli de bouffer la
personne attend les écureuils font
totalement la grève là si je donne un
vin il se passe un truc
peut-être c'est la machine cas là là où
ça va faire tomber des graines oyane
écureuils oui oh non je vais fait peur
ça fait tout mais non j'ai tourné à
bombay pour [ __ ] il y avait un
écureuil qui sera menée il était
incroyable en dans la machine à lui a
fait peur il est parti en vrille avait
sept autres personnes y avaient enfin un
becquerel je vais fait peur je suis
dégoûté bon donc là on en pleine nature
il ya un endroit immense et regarder un
canard voilà c'est lui qui va nous
intéresser à y réclament ils viennent
réclamer ces incroyables attendez je
vais leur donner moi c'est instantané
c'est choquant ok il se régale elle est
bien on vit une époque formidable à
tailler un truc je me demande si c'est
proportionnel le nombre de graines qui
tombe au nombre de bits ce que tu donnes
fargo à la quantité d'argent que tu
donnes si je mets genre 408 est ce qui a
plus de nourriture qui tombe temps je
veux voir
oui oui
et oh là là ils vont tellement mangé
lauder il se ramène il a vu il a vu se
passer quelque chose il vient ce fight
si je donne genre un truc indécent et
moi je suis prêt à tout pour nourrir des
animaux j'adore ça quand j'étais petit
j'allais dans des élevages et je donnais
à manger aux chèvres et où j'adorais ça
si je donne quatre mille beats au [ __ ]
qu'est ce qui va se passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai clairement bouteille âge de cadeaux
c'est en tous les cas ça fait de me dis
que ça tombe est bon tout cela la
question à cebu aux au mois c'est
fabuleux
j'ai adoré ce moment là c'était dingue
wahou lol ce match fou de foot partira à
c'est tellement drôle cette scène de
voir des canards sur nous et il est trop
malade lui au casse toi n'a tricheurs je
voulais je rigole pas wave attendrait
j'allais faire un geyser de grêle hilal
est éjecté l'oiseau attendait retournant
sur la grenouille est ce qu'un animal
non les écureuils et ce qu'est un
écureuil
non c'est décevant ici c'est une caméra
qui filme des lapins oh ils sont mignons
à temps mais j'espère qu'ils vont pas
être mangés au nom c'est horrible si
c'est ça je n'aurais jamais les réponses
annoncées bon il leur a donné des noms
et ou non il serait trop ça dit que mon
gars de leur donner des noms alors qu'il
va les manger à l'arrivée non impossible
je ne peux pas croire ça wahou on est
sur des moutons oies mais sont ils sont
ramollis je pense qu'il ya un gars qui
est passé et qui a dû faire un énorme
dont moi je méconnais ses moutons là ils
sont rassasiés elle a déjà scindé j'ai
le bras long dans le milieu il ya une
autre chaîne de moutons ok on va faire
un test donc là ça tombe là dedans à
temps où ils vont être surpris je pense
qu'ils vont se ruer vers la bouffe
attendait voilà des moutons qui sont
dans le besoin
c'est pas les pourris gâtés la du truc
d'avant ok les gars les gars les gars y
en aura pour tout le monde les gars
inutile de mettre son nez dans ce trio
il y en aura pour tout le monde les gars
est ce que vous êtes prêts sympa
oh non cui s'est rien passé
oh non quand tu donnes plus de 50 buts
en fait c'est des carottes qu'ils ont et
un message en rouge qui dit ne leur
donnait pas de carotte
il y en a plus c'est pas grave on va
faire plein de donation de 50 mots je
mangeais les boutons personne ne se
mettrait entre vous et cette nourriture
à temps mais après je culpabilise un peu
il se met des coups de tête quand même
regarder lui il se met des gros coups de
tête un vrai je m'en veux un peu il y en
a toujours un qui permet au regard des
ruelles règne animal
il n'y a pas de partages c'est pas grave
quand tu commandes des tapas avec tes
amis non non non là ils doivent se
débrouiller ta ils se poussent
[ __ ] il a mis à écouter dans la douche
vous avez vu non mais c'est un peu
triste c'est mal fait genre il s'excite
et j'arrête les conditions ne sont pas
favorables à une entente générale
toujours rien du côté de la grenouille
et aucun des croyants vu un le seul que
dis-je là attendez je vais refaire un
don mais dubois qui va avoir peur ils
sont politiques mais s'en fout en fait
de ce que je donne lui mais il veut
manger du maïs c'est parce que ça
balance ça le truc mais il n'a pas du
tout l'air motivé par sa il est posé
avec son maïs [ __ ] limite je le
dérange est par contre là je découvre
une facette animaux vous allez est vous
allez arrêter de nous prendre de haut
elle nous on est on est à des milliers
de kilomètres on lâche des beats pour
vour nourrir et vous ignorez mais vous
prenez pour qui
alors ici c'est une caméra dans un
bassin et tu peux cap et des commandes
pour qu'elles bougent et le but c'est de
trouver des petits animaux sous l'eau
quoi
[Musique]
pardonnez moi mais ils auraient dû faire
ça dans une eau à un poids un poil plus
clair dans une autre on voit peut-être
éventuellement à plus de 50 cm fin je
veux pas paraître ingrat
allez à là c'est un gars qui avait une
caméra dans sa maison à oiseaux à c'est
trop bien et les voir grandir et tout
c'est trop bien [ __ ] j'ai envie de
faire ça là la chute d'aig d'être un
appartement machine twitch toutes les
soirées gamings et tout finit je vous
met un live en continu vous pouvez voir
des poules et des moutons et c'est réglé
c'est bien plus cool au ya des soirs
pardon excusez moi je vais en live et
sur l'hôte et où il ya des oies
maintenant à la place des canards jamais
je vous nourrit vous êtes des pestes ces
méchants rhinois vous n'êtes jamais à
tuer avec une oie bas je vous conseille
pas non je suis pas du genre à parler
d'un traumatisme que j'ai vécu et est
enfin prêt du tout c'est des [ __ ]
mois met à tomber quoi y'a un écureuil à
un corbeau il ya de tout quand vous
regardez comme ils cohabitent mais je
suis ému il ya une petite embrouille
quand même on reviendra système tu
tombes où il mêle on va fermer les yeux
mais j'ai envie de faire un mur d'écrans
chez moi ou c'est que des live comme ça
en direct plein d'écran avec tous et
l'ags là dedans ça me rend fou est le
fait de savoir que c'est en temps réel
ça change tout c'est bizarre hein ah
j'aime passer un truc la nuit tu dois
voir genre d raccoon bah oui c'est dans
le titre ont pu citer raccoon dépôts
sont des renards il est quelle heure là
midi là bas a whale et 6h de moi en fait
aux faux faux checker le matin celle là
haut je suis trop curieux j'ai envie de
voir clément 3 qui fait le montage en
décalé film ce live le matin à 10 heures
heure française
et on verra du coût des animaux de la
nuit un extrait maintenant de cette même
vu la nuit c'est parti
[Musique]
attendez du coup j'ai envie de voir les
tops clip pour les meilleurs moments qui
sont arrivés sur l'aide des moutons et
des canards parce que c'est du live donc
c'est drôle mais voir ce qu'il peut se
passer je pense est assez rigolo s'y
attendait jarre sur la vie sur la vie
des canadiennes vaches qui est venu ces
troubles aux non j'aurais tellement aimé
à c'est trop bien
waouh parce que tu peux nourrir les
poissons aussi je crois et du coup lille
vient chauffer les poissons incroyable
wahou ok vraiment l'équipe des moutons
ah oui là il avait grave de la laine
[Musique]
il ya des vrais en vous est légal ou ce
qu'on a à faire on n'a rien vu en fait
perdre est en bas à droite
[Musique]
comment ils se mettent sur la gueule
alors qu'ils sont frères et soeurs plus
tard respecter moula vous êtes une
fratrie de huit frères et soeurs eh bien
écoutez les amis ce fut bref mais
intense
qu'est-ce que j'ai ri en les canaris
m'ont tué et les moutons quelle bande de
pourris gâtés ou de rageux ya pas
d'entre-deux je voulais trop vous
montrer ce truc d'animaux en live en
fait je pense que le live va y avoir de
plus en plus de trucs comme ça auquel on
n'avait pas forcément pensé genre je
n'ai pas du tout pensé moi ça en fait
même si j'y avais pensé je me serais dit
que comme les fermes et tousser dans des
zones reculées bas il n'ya pas la
connexion qu'il faut pour pouvoir live
et en fait si délai à la connexion et en
plus il ya des gars combien et ford ouf
dans l'installation de plomelin de
caméras je trouve ça vraiment marrant et
c'est détente quoi donc tu bosses tu te
mets un petit live comme ça d'animaux
sur ton deuxième écran tu es trop bien
imagine un jour il ya un gars et le fait
qu'un humain qu'est ce que j'ai à me
dire merci en rien la vie de j'espère ça
vous a fait marrer moi je trouve ça
vraiment drôle opers il a découvert un
truc
hop là la petite anecdote intéressante
le repas de famille allez allez faire
vos intéressant mais à bientôt c'est
ciao
[Musique]
on